close encounters of the huh kind horses
in the night skies cowboys and aliens
and predators all feature in jordan
peel's newest film nope and you don't
need access to any x-files to understand
it all keep watching for the confusing
moments in nope explained
early in the film nope introduces oj
haywood and his father otis senior the
two run a horse ranch with a side
business of wrangling the animals for
hollywood films and their intro scene
starts off pretty quiet and peaceful
that is until an array of objects start
raining from the sky like daggers one of
which fatally wounds otis the scene is
pretty clearly explained via the later
events in the film but it can be a bit
confusing at first while oj is told by
the authorities that the items likely
fell out of an airplane he doesn't buy
that explanation eventually he discovers
that a giant alien monster is to blame a
creature that vomits out any non-organic
material after feeding so presumably the
alien was passing overhead after a meal
cloaked in its cloud cover and
unfortunately decided to spit up some
keys and coins directly over haywood
ranch
following the brutal opening combo of
gordy's home and otis death knope
launches into a full opening credits
sequence something that's seen less and
less in modern movies but common to the
classic genre flicks that peel pulls
from the only thing is it's hard to tell
exactly what's going on during the
opening credits the names appear in the
middle of an oscillating landscape of
waves almost like the viewer is sitting
inside an otherworldly blanket fort
eventually the camera zooms in to reveal
a man riding a horse a clip later
explained to be the first movie ever
made it's impossible to discern what's
happening your first time watching the
nope opening credits but after going
through the full film it becomes much
clearer the camera shot that displays
the credits is the same shot used to
show the inside of the alien's mouth
later on the flags from the decoy are
repeatedly shown dangling out the
billowing maw and the shot is used again
in the star lasso experience scene when
the creature devours a whole show's
worth of people this could just be a fun
easter egg for folks on their second
viewing but it can also be read as
thematically significant ricky refers to
the ufo as the viewers and that's also
what you are when you're watching the
movie rattling off the cast and crew
from the perspective of the monster
makes that connection even more explicit
and the texture of the alien also
foreshadows its final form
after getting kicked off the set of a
commercial oj and emerald head to the
wild west theme park jupiter's claim
owned by the enigmatic ricky park
specifically oj goes there to sell
another horse lucky to ricky having
already sold him almost a dozen while in
the meeting o.j brings up the notion of
buying a few of the horses back which
causes ricky to pause and eventually
change the subject this scene makes a
lot more sense with the context of the
rest of the movie it's implied that
ricky has been experimenting with the
alien for some time by feeding it horses
a grim act that eventually becomes the
centerpiece of his star lasso experience
ricky probably balks at the idea of
selling oj the horses back because well
they're not around anymore instead of
discussing the issue ricky switches
gears and tells emerald all about his
experience shooting the sitcom gordy's
home the site of the violent incident
pictured in the first scene this moment
also foreshadows the star lasso
experience as it shows ricky's ability
to ignore trauma and potential danger in
the interest of turning a profit
after setting up security cameras all
around the ranch and preparing for the
ufo's return oj has what seems at first
to be a real alien encounter in the
horse's stables while investigating some
strange activity he comes upon three
big-headed beings covered in coarse
black hair it's one of the film's
spookier scenes but it ends up being a
complete fake out as the aliens are
nothing more than three kids in costumes
specifically they're the children of
ricky park showing up later on in the
same costumes to perform at the star
lasso experience after their cover is
blown they tell oj not to mess with
jupiter's claim and quickly leave oj
seems to think it's because emerald
stole one of the park's horse statues
but there might be more at play than
simple payback it's suggested at various
points that ricky is interested in
purchasing the whole haywood ranch given
that his newest business venture
involves chasing down a ufo that lives
in the area that makes a lot of sense
considering that it's possible the kid's
prank would have been just the start of
a campaign to compel oj to sell
businessmen using skeevy tactics to
force people to sell property is a
classic western trope and it feels right
at home in nope
arguably the most graphic and striking
scene in all of nope happens after the
alien eats the people of the star lasso
experience the creature descends
directly over the haywood house and
begins releasing all manner of objects
coins keys and a giant statue of a horse
all get jettisoned out of the creature's
maw but it also spews a veritable
hailstorm of blood and viscera from its
recently consumed meal in other words
the alien starts raining literal blood
over the haywood house
[Applause]
the spark for this horrifying moment is
the aliens feast at jupiter's claim it
sucks up way more people and other
assorted items than ever before so it
makes sense that its release ends up
being so massive wyatt chooses to dump
all over the haywood house specifically
however is a bit less clear the best
explanation is probably oj's own it's a
territorial animal and it's marking its
territory
despite being one of the two lead
protagonists of nope o.j haywood doesn't
get a ton of overt character development
he's a quiet and solitary man who seems
to prefer the company of horses to that
of humans but he also doesn't seem to
love the hollywood work that his father
pushed him into even ufo attacks and
reigning blood barely get a rise out of
oj who willingly returns to the ranch
time after time despite the inherent
danger
no
why does oj do this knowing that he
could get abducted and devoured you
could read it as oj wanting the money
emerald claims that a great shot of the
alien will make them rich and famous
which would definitely be a motivating
factor for most people but is it the
kind of thing that oj would care about
as oj tells emerald before returning to
the ranch he's got mouths to feed he
clearly feels a familial obligation to
take care of the horses and keep the
ranch going he stays in the hollywood
business in large part because it's what
otis would have wanted and he may see
exposing the alien as a way of paying
tribute to his father as well if there
is money to be made from the alien it
would mean that oj wouldn't need to sell
any more horses which seems good enough
for him
the climax of nope is a complicated
sequence and there are a lot of things
that are easy to miss your first time
watching it essentially the whole group
lays out an elaborate plan to capture
the alien fully on camera each character
has their own motivations with angel
wanting to expose extraterrestrials to
the public emerald seeking out the fame
and fortune a great shot could bring and
holst seeking out some kind of artistic
achievement by making an impossible shot
the shot the money shot undeniable
singular
the oprah shot
one of the more confusing parts of the
plan involves the dozens of skydancers
that the crew sets up all around the
ranch at first they look like they're
meant as distractions but they're
actually a sort of radar system because
anything electrical conks out when near
the alien you can tell where the
creature is by which skydancers get
turned off the electrical issues are
also why holst brings an old-fashioned
hand crank camera which doesn't rely on
any modern power source to operate
finally oj uses a parachute-laden string
of flags the same kind that temporarily
incapacitates the alien earlier in the
movie as a means to briefly scare it off
once the ufo gets on him and he rides
into position for the shot he releases
the string into the air to dissuade the
alien from eating him and lucky the plan
works and both oj and lucky make it out
in one piece
for his climactic ride on lucky oj
chooses to wear the orange crew hoodie
he got from working on the set of the
scorpion king with his father he
mentions the film much earlier during a
conversation with emerald who shares
that jean jacket the horse that was
supposed to be her first was the one
brought along for the shoot the scorpion
king generally seems to symbolize the
complicated relationship that the
haywood siblings had with their father
it was the first job that oj got brought
along for it marked a schism between
otis and emerald and because jean jacket
didn't even end up being used in the
film it also represents unfinished
business he even goes so far as to dub
the alien jean jacket
all of these little details surely play
into oj's decision to wear the hoodie he
brings in all these loose ends from his
relationship with his father and it
seems like he gets some closure by
confronting the alien of course the
hoodie is functionally relevant as its
bright orange color is easy for both the
alien and the rest of the crew to see
and it's big enough for oj to wrap
himself in what looks to be a
bulletproof vest for extra protection
emerald even sews some i-like reflectors
into the back of the hood to help get
the creature's attention when the time
comes
just as everything is set for the big
alien shoot the crew gets disrupted by
the surprise arrival of a paparazzi
reporter riding in on an electric
motorcycle with a striking chrome helmet
that completely obscures his face the
reporter quickly begins badgering
emerald with questions about the strange
incidents in the area because he looks
like a robot from the future it's
natural to assume at first that the
motorcycle man has some ulterior motive
for being there but in the end he just
dies in a relatively unceremonious
fashion the main reasons for him showing
up seem to be getting emerald a
motorcycle something she references
early on and offering another bit of
meta commentary like holst the reporter
is there to get the shot even as he's
lying on the ground about to die he
implores oj to take a picture of him
nope dabbles heavily in the idea of
seeing and being seen on camera or
otherwise for a guy so obsessed with
being seen and getting the perfect shot
it's more than a little ironic that he
was eaten by a creature that definitely
saw him
shockingly the whole plan to capture
footage of the ufo goes perfectly at
least until host decides to take a
camera with him up a hill where he's
quickly eaten by the monster holst is a
curious character throughout the film to
say the least whenever he's shown
editing film it's mostly nature shots of
predators fighting he agrees to help out
when emerald promises an opportunity to
get the impossible shot which suggests
that he's still chasing some kind of
artistic peak and yet once he has the
shot holst seems to lose all sense of
himself we don't deserve the impossible
he says before climbing up the hill with
his camera this seems like a declaration
of intent holst willingly travels to
higher and more dangerous ground with
the camera in tow in an attempt to make
the shot even more perfect and what's
more perfect than what he already has
more of the alien at golden hour he
films the aliens approach and attack
even as his camera is destroyed along
with him he gets the shot at the
ultimate price check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you